how do you feel that the female leads
differ in Indian cinema versus the
female leads that are in American cinema
what type of personality traits I think
it depends on the film's itself
a lot of the Bollywood movies are
musicals so I feel that they're here at
heroines are more glamorous and but
sometimes depending on if it's a drama
they can't be unglamorous and they do
play the you know the character and I
think there's a difference between
Bollywood and Indian cinema where Indian
cinema focuses more on the everyday
people and their stories more than their
scale skips sorry skillet assume of the
Bollywood but it's fine like you know it
is not you are in Bollywood it's fine
and this lot of regional films as well
like the Tamil Malayalam films signal
expands
South Asian region and I love it all and
I love Hollywood movies as well because
that's what I do I act more on a
Hollywood TV and film and I think
Hollywood is like the heroines more they
may prepare more for the character that
they're playing then for the clown so
but I think both is not wrong I think
it's what it is what it is so it's I
enjoy both
it seems as if Bollywood stars are
treated basically as royalty and there's
such an exuberant fanbase for them with
great power comes great responsibility
so what would you say to your fans that
probably hang on every word and watch
your tweets and and are very dependent
on what you think I would say to take
responsibility for your own actions
just-joan sometimes yeah you can't help
but be in your circumstance but whatever
happens that know that you're strong
then you don't have to resort to drink
or drugs or stuff like that that you can
get through things talk to people just
know we all know what's going on around
you and it's okay to be moderate like
half why mine's in a while you know
that's why it's your own judgement but
just be responsible for yourself and
just enjoy life and just keep moving for
love-life that's excellent thank you
written by speed so Brian what brings
you here tonight
see this Bollywood film and - you know I
have not seen I've been to my first
apartment for Bollywood and I have heard
that there's this new 3d thing being
used with it so I'm curious to see how
they do you know I'm curious I know it
hasn't been done before so our projects
I say high expectations I look forward
to them doing well they should say so I
expect them to do really hope that you
so yeah so that's why I'm here to
support right what do you say to an
actor that says hey I just want to do
the creative I'm not a business person
hi
you're a friend of mine being a I'm much
more on the creative side you have to be
more business oriented as they tell you
and it really does help to get that to
get that insight because just being
creative you can get there the lack of a
better expression really screwed on your
business side but I think you need a
business side in order to move your
creative side forward so I think they
need to go hand in hand and you gotta
concentrate on both and what do you do
to kind of get your mojo back because
vegan actors between LA is a really
really disheartening thing when you feel
maybe like you know what I'm ready to
leave LA what do you do to recharge
never wanted to leave LA maybe go on for
vacation for about three weeks but go
see a show go see a show jump back into
class revisit your favorite movie do
something or your favorite actor or
something where you just read breathe
maybe your favorite book just to get
rien spired because going to see a shows
the way to really do it because you
can't get good seats because that stuff
to see their faces and to see what they
do and to its really reinvigorate you
so you see a show appreciate it thank
you thank you so gentlemen what would
you tell fellow actors about getting the
business side of their careers ready
not just the artistic side there's so
many artistic people say you know what I
don't want to deal with the money side I
don't want to deal with the the
logistics of my career I just want to
work on the craft is that true can you
just leave that to someone else even in
the beginning oh really I mean I would
say invest a little bit of your money
and a good accountant or a good business
magic because they're dealing with your
money so you want someone that's
reputable that deals with good people
and knows what they're doing with your
money and then social media is kind of
important nowadays so some sort of
online presence whether that's your
website or Facebook fan page or Twitter
and then having a good agent because
they'll obviously filter a lot of the
rubbish out and only give me the stuff
that you really need to read yeah I'm
the businessman and the last national
could you deal with it what your
business yeah you'll be good at ten
percent twenty fine see the worst
business well speaking of Twitter with
with great power comes great
responsibility so do you feel any type
of sort of weight on your back to have
responsible tweets are you conscious of
what you put out there so that if your
fans see it it's it's acceptable it's
it's well I mean my Twitter page is a
reflection of me and I I'm not racist or
sexist or homophobic I'm not fascist or
you know I don't have elements of my
personality so I might be a little
aggressive to someone who's being nasty
towards me but I'll never throw the
first stone you know
and I'll usually just show that people
are being inappropriate and leave it
that you know but if someone gets nasty
then and I feel like it I might point
out that they're they've been badly but
I don't I don't tend to swear on Twitter
I don't tend to say lead in this
inflammatory for no good reason so if
someone prompts you it's on basically
yeah and I'll call out people that I
think are behaving badly like I've
called out Bill O'Reilly a few times and
he is more than a few times but for the
most bias friendly applause I'm kind of
new to the whole tweet thing and as I
say I do it through other my band so
it's not totally personal like all the
guys in the band tweet stuff and I kind
of keep it as quite a funny thing and
something to put some faultless and I
don't really use it you know if you put
of course any sort of personal beliefs
or anything really you know I keep it
quite you know it's about the binds
really and lastly what do you do to
recharge
I know la gets a little bit hectic
sometimes sometimes rejection sets in or
people become a little bit jaded with
the business what do you do to recharge
so you feel better
I travel quite a bit you know I mean if
I'm in LA and I don't have time to go
somewhere on a plane then I'll drive to
Joshua Tree or Palm Springs or Santa
Barbara just try and get away for the
weekend you know hang around with people
that aren't actors apart from Billy who
is an actor you know I'll hang around
with people in the music business so all
people in different walks of life and
then Billy and I both enjoy surfing here
and there
yogurt fantastic yeah I think travel is
a great one and yogurt is probably the
biggest thing to kind of de-stress with
perspective on things
all right thank you guys Thank You Jay
what you say is the difference between
lead actresses and their personality
traits portrayed in Indian cinema versus
American lead actresses actually quite
sort of quite sort of becoming smaller I
would say over the years I do think
women that's portrayed universally there
is you know it has still has to improve
but I do think that doesn't matter where
they're coming from there are more
challenging parts in India and out and
as opposed to in Hollywood and I think
it's a wonderful change so I think the
gap is getting smaller I would think yes
and what do you say to the recent ban on
the film India I think right now they
have two weeks they're putting on it and
some people are calling it cultural
terrorism what would you say to that
well I do think during artists if you're
a painter musician dough maker I do
think you have the right to be able to
communicate with the audience
your thoughts your your your you know
what your what you believe in and I
respect that
it's it's the artistic license that I
think everybody should have with your
artist or not the freedom of speech is
very important I think it's it should be
supported and protected yes it appears
that that Bollywood is so enthusiastic
about their actors and actresses that
it's almost like they're royalty whereas
in America they're definitely
enthusiastic but it doesn't seem the
same exuberance so as great power comes
a lot of responsibility
you never yellow wait to really make
sure that you send the right message and
and do the right sort of thing so to
speak because you know you have so many
people depending on what you say it's
true and on and I think films
universally they have a message I mean
I've I've actually seen those that have
changed my life so I think the medium
itself is you have a great
responsibility and I hope that everybody
does right by it
so yes Roger what brings you here
tonight I'm here to support my friends
who are part of the cast and crew and
Kamal Haasan sir who's the director and
you know the lead actor in the film is
one of my idols growing up in India and
he's one of the reasons I am an actor
today in Hollywood and I'm also working
in on some projects in Chennai and
Bombay in India and it'd be such a dream
come true to work with him in the future
and so I'm here to support all the cast
and crew and all of the hard work that's
gone into making this film and it's
beautiful you know Pacific theatres and
the Grove the kind of hangout place in
LA for families so what other actors
come to you for advice and they say I'm
in a lull in my career can you show me
what I should do to kind of drum up work
for myself what do you tell them you
know it depends on the type of situation
they're in you know I think it's a
difference between being active as
houses it's usually when you wait for
things to happen that you you've come
across those kinds of difficulties but
you know the way that I approach it is
the same thing I tell them is to you
know create work for yourself you know
if you're good at writing write
something and get it produced whether
it's a short film or a feature film
whatever size of the project it doesn't
matter you know entered into film
festivals things like that so that you
the recognition going for your work and
also keeps your artistic you know kind
of energy alive so that's one of the
things I tell you know friends or even
you know mentees you know people who
come to me for advice is to is to be
proactive and create the work for
yourself and lastly you know couply
Hassan has such a loyal fan base and and
he's really like royalty yes I in India
do you feel the same responsibility
because Indian cinema seems to really
just put their their actors on a whole
nother level than maybe America does
with their actors I do feel that sense
of responsibility for sure because you
know representing the Diaspora the
community that we're part of we're not a
very huge community we're about 1% of
the US population so we're certainly a
minority but we're a minority that's
achieved a lot you know everything from
you know advisors in the White House to
the governor of Louisiana to you know
activists in in politics and in the you
know in the public health space in in
society and you know I feel privileged
and blessed to be able to represent them
you know I do play a lot of doctors
which is the common stereotype you know
amongst Indian you know professionals
and you know but we've done well for
ourselves because of Education and hard
work and I feel very privileged to
represent them and I feel that
responsibility definitely and and you
were so right you know Kamal Haasan sir
is a superstar in India you know he is
idolized you know like like no one else
and you know it's such a dream to be
able to work with them in the future
because he set such a high bar for
himself with the quality of filmmaking
he does and he pushes the technical in a
technological envelope in terms of
hiring people from Hollywood to come in
and do special effects and stunts and
you know
these things and it's just a pleasure to
watch his projects and I grew up with
his work as a as a kid in India and you
know he's definitely one of the reasons
I'm an actor today so he's a he's a huge
inspiration for me thank you so much
your films have screened in Sundance or
a film of yours who screams and dances
all right now no no I just came back
from Sundance I had a couple of friends
who had films there I was just just
supporting this year and you know I
produce independent film as well as
acting and so you know it's always good
to go and so for a couple of my friends
after this year okay sorry about that so
so knowing that you are part of sort of
the Sundance machine or you've been
there who've seen it and so many indie
filmmakers strive for that Sundance
premiere they always think they're gonna
get it
you think it's realistic for a lot of
people to try for it or maybe try
smaller festivals and and spread
themselves out further I don't know if
I'm being clear with that but do you
think that's a really thing yeah you
know it's it's funny I've produced two
features now and we've both for both of
our features we submitted the Sundance
we didn't get in so you know we're right
in the thick of that you know those
opposed to makers trying to get in you
know I've been a couple years in a row
now to try to see what I can find in
trends and and types of films that they
look for you know realistically you know
it always like anything else whether
it's theatres its movie its TV it's
always a script it starts with the
script you know you have to have a great
script and everything else falls into
place and I think I think you always
have to try write it if you don't try
you don't get you know and and your
really being focused and and bringing
good people on board your project you
have a better shot you know Sundance
likes to bring back a lot of their past
alums so I've noticed a lot of people
embrace and bring in certain crew
members that have you know whether
they're cast or crew have been in the
film we're involved with the film that
was at the festival so you know there
are little things you can try to feel
along the way to embrace and hopefully
you know catch the eye open and are you
ever planning to use crowdfunding to
fund any of your budgets or you know we
haven't for any of our features we there
have been a couple of short films and
stuff that I've helped produce that that
we did use crowdfunding for for features
you know it's it's it's a very realistic
possibility I mean there's so much that
that is you know that's coming in the
way of crowdfunding there's a site
called film break that I have a film
that we are sort of developing within as
a tentpole project and it's sort of a
different approach to crowdfunding where
this is it's sort of generated through
social media your awareness and your
tracking and through them they have
compiled a list of investors and people
that want to invest in film so you know
it's instead of it campaigning to get
you know money you're campaigning to get
the attention and sort of just the you
know the social media following that
will then turn over and hopefully into
other people so there's all sorts of new
companies like that developing and I
think that's you know it's kind of an
interesting way too because you don't
always have to be held by an investor or
obligate to that because you know you
have their perks that you would you give
out aside from that you know you're not
you know creatively I think artists like
the fact that they're not held back by
an investor you know saying you have to
do this or haptic with that person in
the film you know right can an
independent filmmaker be too independent
for their own good I don't know I don't
know what that means really I'm sure
every you know I think if you're doing
it you're doing it you know that's
that's the hard thing especially in
today's society you know it's one of the
things I always tell my friends it's
like and the only reason that we're
producing films now is because it's like
I knew a lot of people that had various
talents and different things and it was
like there should never be a moment
where we're not working because you know
especially with today you know in
technology and cameras and everything
it's even on a consumer level it's so
cheap to get professional quality so I
think it's always possible to do stuff
and that for me you know I always
embrace just keep working thank you very
much
and what brings you here tonight well
I'm here to support the film you know
it's the Indian culture
and hey it's pretty intriguing to me so
I'm here just to do just that and enjoy
the good people good vibes a good time
I'm curious do you feel an obligation to
keep up on social media to let your fans
know what you're up to and and how do
you deal with that because I know it can
be a time suck I mean it takes a lot of
time to be on Twitter and it takes a lot
of time gonna be on Facebook you know in
today's world that said it's definitely
important to social network I'm probably
one of the worst social networkers but
that's why is that there's times there's
so many tweets and stuff that I'm like
I'll try to reply to everybody but it's
impossible it's yeah I mean maybe it's
not impossible but you between us
somebody to retweet or tweet at you and
then you were fine then they replied to
Mort as so and then you're like trying
to keep up so it's kind of tough but you
know try your hardest and just expect
for the best so what advice would you
give someone else that's in your shoes
that has people that are kind of curious
out what's he up to what would you tell
them because it is overwhelming and what
where's the balance well I think the
only thing you could really tell anybody
is hey just you know everyone lives
their life just like they do nobody
means to neglect or reject anyone they
can't you know contact your reach out
it's not because they're ignoring you or
anything it's like they have their own
life's too you know
they're human just like you are so and
the day and I just keep living my life
and like for example that's right now I
have a huge announcement coming soon
it's so so major for me and just it's a
big it's a big part of our country that
we follow together so I can't really get
into the I can't get to the hints right
cuz it'll be like boom that's what it is
but most of that you know and then
shortly after that I mean I mean I mean
theatrical things now as well so I have
some movies that are coming up and made
you in a shop back in the ring concrete
some more titles those Championships
again so yeah ready and lastly what do
you do when when you just want to get
away like what do you do to recharge I'm
kind of a different breed I guess I go
out and I surf I rode bike I get away
like that
mentally sometimes I'll go travel which
I go I go out of the country just by
myself I don't wanna be with anybody so
I just grab a plane ride and the next
you know I'm in like London or I'm in
France I mean you name it Caribbean
Puerto Rico anywhere I just I get away
by myself though so this kind of a great
escape me
you know when I come back I'm just like
gosh soaking in the world again and then
start over so yeah it's a good a
statement I'm gonna try it actually yeah
thank you right now all right thank you
very much every to you by ticker Leilani
what brings you here tonight well I'm
Kamali's rounded guy wears many hats I'm
very impressed with people that could
just do that only acting but writing
producing directing I'm so I'm not a
leader no I'm not I just I'm not
organized like that okay but I'm
impressed with people they can and do
and have that vision and can put it all
together so she'd be very very
what scene in the film or which actress
have you seen where you said you know
what I want to do that I want to do that
out I can tell you ladies see in a movie
that I went okay maybe I should not be
an actress because she is just
I'm so impressed
Oh God can you share it or is it you
know what Jennifer Aniston always just
comes to mind that she is so such a
leading lady type of
and yet she's so hilarious and funny and
that she has the capacity to really move
people
in a kind of an everyday ordinary way
and really get to the heart of the funny
to submit it it's been about hard thing
to do when you look as gorgeous issues
she get it comes to mind
and lastly what's kryptonite for an
actor kryptonite not to go right to the
negative but because it is such a hard
profession and a lot of artists are so
sensitive we all are but artists I think
more so and that's what makes them great
artists what's what's the kryptonite for
an actor I think just having the this
strength to carry on because so many
times are stopped at maybe not making
enough money to pay the bills or just
hearing no so many times it's just
finding that inner strength and for me
it's family life I have three children
and to me that is just where it's at for
me and it's really given me the survival
just carry on said that's my kryptonite
having a great family support system
very grounding when when you're chasing
after a toddler or something it is
although a minor in college high school
and
I wasn't thinking that but okay Wow
babies takraw laughter but yeah it's
been a very grounding experience
motherhood rocks all right well thank
you what brings you here tonight man
we're here to support the independent
film today airing my publicist and check
it out they didn't have a good time well
so many people have seen Project Runway
what do you think the public doesn't
know about the fashion industry we know
it to be may be cutthroat but what are
some surprises that might actually be
positive things the public isn't aware
of with a fashion industry about the
bat's industry in general I think there
are a lot of collaborations going on
right now in the industry that I think
makes fashionable more exciting we're a
creative minds we get together with
other cultures like India I've been
talking to some Indian suppliers about
using some of their textiles and designs
in my line so that will also bring you
know my products so another level will
bring a new element to it so I think
that's something that's happening now in
fashion that I'm really tried about of
all time what's the best model who knows
how to sort of wear it well and it has
sort of I mean for me I thought Jia was
the best model I thought she was just
she had this thing where she was just
there was like a duality to her what
about you you look at your favorite
models little bit more I can't even
answer that question why they might be
listening oh yeah maybe they're maybe
they're from the past you don't have to
tell them now so they're not modeling
anymore
you know what that's a tough question I
really would have to think about a
little more Princess Grace all right
Thank You Betty sure you're welcome
well a good friend of mine does
documentaries in India and I heard the
describe
next thing is
do you remember what your life was like
before you were on a series and what you
did everyday to drum up work for
yourself okay I remember what life was
like and yeah that was great I was in
three theatre companies and I was doing
from Shakespeare to classical to drama
and it's been directing the stage
fighting everything hustle so very very
busy and I got to pick and choose what
roles I wanted to do in Hollywood
I did not to go in for a day player is
that yeah because I was so busy on stage
and understated so that was good and
then a role came along for me on NYPD
Blue
he's out of the theater companies and
stay with that and then a couple of
months later I got a shoot so what do
you think actors should know about the
business side even even if they're just
small time and they're just getting
their toe in the water what should they
know about the business side of act
because so many people don't want to go
there but it's necessary
three things you got to know question
bus hours giving this business action
flows to save you money whenever you can
always work on your craft you know it is
it is a set of muscles that need to be
in there
last year if it's really your dream
there's nothing that will stop you
and that's what really helped me I mean
when work isn't flowing I know that I'll
get myself in an active job and if I'm
really working hard I know to put away
the money so that I when it slows down
I'm still okay I'm not buying the goods
today so that I'm not suffering tomorrow
and it's it's been good vice all along
but even as a theatre actor the same
things that I'm doing for players are
doing tours I've put in the money away
so and that's a hard thing to remember
because it is an ebb and flow business
and lastly you think you'll be on
Twitter one day I don't think I have the
capacity to get to Twitter it's
addicting yeah once you try it I guess
I'll never know the first tweet is free
did you say is the difference in
personality types of the way that women
are portrayed in Indian cinema
I think luckily perceptions are changing
a lot and it's a lot of blending
happening but I am proud to say that
even though in Indian cinema women are
portrayed in a very traditional fashion
in some movies I think that is also
great because it it reflects an era that
still exists in some areas of India
whereas the modern woman that's
portrayed who is similar to the Western
woman that's the changing diaspora so I
believe that I was like both things to
co-exist and that's what I try to do in
my first home production I just released
my first home production and I played
sign of a bilateral role where one of me
was very traditional and the other me
was extremely modern and question eyes
it hasn't been released yet okay
touching it's hundred-day in theaters
day after tomorrow
okay India and it's called John Lima
side-by-side and how has it been
received how is the more radical side of
that character been received infected
was very it was a shock to people to see
me on that side because it's not just
the traditional but I play as a
methodological aspect of Indian cinema
which is our self-transforming program
this beautiful woman that's part of our
Lord in India so one of my goals was
that and it was kind of an unexpected
jolt that they received and I think it's
really well received because it's
touching it's hundred today it sounds
like a WoW now I know with Indian cinema
especially with Bollywood
you know stars are basically royalty
whereas in these states it seems like
they're definitely revered but not as
much so and with great power and a lot
of responsibility comes what type of
responsibility do you feel to your fans
because I'm sure on all the sites they
want to know what you're up to and and
everything what do you feel as a duty to
them in fact the funny thing is I have a
I would say I do unlike myself in real
life I'm a doctor as well so in that
sense I think my responsibility as as a
responsible citizen of society is
already being fulfilled in my role as a
doctor and in real life and I took up
acting as a hobby and now it's turning
into almost a bilateral profession
because I love the world of movies so a
responsibility yes I think just by being
a strong citizen who loves humanity who
wants to do good for Humanity I don't
think I need to be a better example than
that you know yeah I think I think
that's pretty much it now don't you
think that that grounds you so much
though because you're dealing with
medicine and all the things that you
know life and death that people are
facing then it really grounds you it
does and sometimes that's our negative
because I'm too grounded you know but on
the other hand I have so many very life
experiences as an
agency room physician in the United
States that I can but that part of my
soul which has seen the the various
extremes of human life and death
situations into the intensity in my
movies so I think I have a little bit of
an extra edge over many of the other
great actresses why I really respect in
a door but I like to think I have a
little extra edge because it was extra
like right and lastly what do you say
about the film being banned for a few
weeks back in a coma Hudson's hometown
or actually in India well I sure it is
seen by everyone because it is the world
of cinema it is a it is a world of
entertainment it is a world of just
creating awareness you know so I I
really would like every film that is
made so well and not do with this
stellar stellar person such as come
Angie I want the whole world to see it
and I sure what it gets cleared up yes
and I'm the people are you seeing it
myself now
thank you very much appreciated and what
brings you ladies here tonight
well we are involved with another
project that has a very similar crew
group as this one so a few of the crew
members from this project are also
involved in ours it's called trainers
which is a sitcom about personal
trainers in Los Angeles
and we're premiering on the Fox lot in
May and I co-created Perot and accident
and Alexa is our director
excited if someone asks you to to write
a book on coming to LA as an actress
what would the Reader's Digest version
be okay when you come to LA as an
actress two things you should know one I
stole this take fountain and to get a
day job that is very flexible yet you
make the most amount of money in the
least amount of time I just had a lot of
life experiences as an actor you're
saying yeah yeah really a lot of life
experiences and you bring that into your
work take acting classes you know
workshop meet casting directors meet
directors meet show runners of
television shows and create work yes but
you don't be done and I think they help
do you have to be creative and that's
why you're doing it and create it so how
do people get those life experiences
maybe they're from a small town and
they've had oh you okay and they've had
kind of a good good life maybe nothing
too tragic how would you get those life
experiences in a safe way that's a great
question and I think
well I went to I lived abroad by one of
my ears at college and I think just like
Olympus that as many things that you can
do to travel or taking art classes or I
don't know interacting with people you'd
normally wouldn't have interacted with
just going outside your comfort zone in
general I think really if I hurry go to
art museums go to movies people watch
and like Salus said you know generate
material think outside the box and
really think that you know nobody stops
you with you if you want to do this for
su those dreams and you can make it
happen
me frenchmen misfit group of traders who
are trying to keep their small Jim alive
the other big equinoxes and Elli
businesses and
yeah and itself obviously accommodation
silliness and funny situations in the
gym as you can probably imagine and this
is going on YouTube or you're pitching
into a network for pitching at ten
different networks and then it is
formatted as a web series also so we can
either do the web series or the pilot
and see what happens what takeoff would
make you ladies best of luck series okay
all right
pooja Kumar and my twitter handle is
pooja Kumar and why and you can go to
pooja Kumar Greece we come with us and
as a director to work with how would he
give you notes and feedback him as a
director I mean as simply as fantastic
you know he
he seamlessly transitions between an
actor the director the producer which
has been absolutely fantastic so for me
it was really sort of humbling
experience because he explained
everything so sort of like very
peacefully and he's a very intimidating
person so when you first meet him you're
sort of scared because he's a man who's
done over 200 movies you want to
basically you know impressive
and sort of strive for excellent so
you're nervous you know the beginning
and then slowly you know you meet him he
sort of calms you down and and because
he wants you to do so well you actually
step outside your own comfort which i
think is a rare quality and I think it's
a sign of a great director yeah how
similar is your character in the film to
the way you are in real life and what
are the differences but I wonder if he
did cast me based on you know it's a
visual medium and I think I've identify
what nirupama
I play a scientist she's nuclear on
and you know I've always I've liked
science all my whole life so I had that
sort of you know kind of closeness to
that and you know she's sort of been
secure about who she is then I think
initially as we all like as we're
younger or a little insecure about who
we are and then as a girl door we become
secure with what what was in skin
I think that's what her character is
about to it that she's initially sort of
insecure about who she is and then
slowly slowly she transitions into this
woman that sort of becomes the becomes
confident but they had a little bit of
quirkiness so I'm kind of like that too
you think that makes her more likable so
people aren't as intimidated by her so
you know and you know coming to write
such a beautiful female character you
know whether it's one line or five lines
or ten nine you write such beautiful and
powerful roles for them so I think
that's why you know sort of you bring
through the quirkiness he brings in the
smartness they bring them you know
something that I think everyone can
identify in Indian cinema cinema excuse
me is so exuberant about their actors
and actresses it's almost like they are
actual royalty where is it American
cinema is a little bit different do you
feel a great responsibility to the
people of India to share things that I
mean I know there's so much on websites
and it it's a lot you know in the
are very popular because of I think
music the fashion literature and so I
think you know we set up they have a
duty and I think if we don't sort of
inspire people or expand the knowledge
then we're doing ourselves a disservice
and lastly uh
because the film is banned for a few
weeks in India what do you have to say I
think Salman Rushdie said it was a
cultural emergency because this film is
this held back about the situation you
know the movie is something that we
should all see where artists really live
in a democracy we live in a free world
we should be able to show anything that
we feel strongly about and I'm really
sad that people would go against someone
like
who is a man who is for the people he
has always fought for human rights he
fights for people whether they're Muslim
or Christian or Hindus it doesn't matter
so it's making me very angry and very
sad at the same time so I think it we
all shouldn't pull together and show the
support it'll make a victim great thank
you so much appreciated how is kamila
Hassan as a director how did he give you
notes how did he let you know to change
this or that Kamal Hassan is a
perfectionist in the most beautiful way
I think he's the chaplain of our today
he is a guy who was who is versatile
creates things very spontaneous and
wants very specific visions but he'll
sit down with to you a day before and
really go and work with you you know
speaking Hindi and Thummim was prime my
difficult thing I speak Hindi speaking
Tamil I never spoke down though so way
to go through it phonetically very
giving very generous to have a legend
soul so giving is is humbling and an
unbelievable
and sorry Salman Rushdie is calling the
banning of the film in India a cultural
emergency what do you have to say well
it's interesting I'm in someone else's
film called Midnight's Children and
that's coming out in the next week as
well February 1st Salman Rushdie was
banned for as a law for you know
for Satanic Verses however I think it's
insane I think that absolutely insane
because cinema is about about helping
society not bringing it back it's
fanaticism that holds back to some
society so I think it's a regressive
thing that's going on right now in India
we need to change that we're gonna stand
up for this because this has to change
you know I think what I agree what was
Russia's at that quote it was a cultural
emergency that he felt that writers
filmmakers artists etc need to keep our
nerve and continue to work no matter
what I agree absolutely with mr. Rushdie
it is a cultural emergency it's a
wake-up call to India to not censor to
say that this is important and this is
what life is about
art is essential fanaticism is all will
always be there but only art contains
the world
and lastly Indian cinema and Bollywood
especially have such an exuberance for
their fans it's like they are sleepy for
their stars it's like they treat them as
royalty do you feel a great sense of
responsibility to what you say and what
you tweet and the messages that you
absolutely I think it should be everyone
who has any type of power whatever the
Indian cinema or Western cinema I do a
lot of work in both let's go to work
here and there if your Twitter of your
facebook if you speak it is we are the
voice you know if you've got a
personality use it use it to change the
world someone like them unless one is
doing that someone like I'm a clown in
Bollywood is doing that
people need to step up and change the
world because the only people listen or
the people when they when people speak
of personalities when you've got a
follower it is a responsibility at a
duty because we've got listeners so
let's continue to listen and follow and
create change wonderful thank you very
much and mr. Cooper on your Twitter I
noticed that you have hashtag
responsible tweets and we've been
talking with a lot of the people here
that when there is great power there's
also great responsibility to have a
message that's for the people
why do you advocate that what are some
of the things that you preach to people
that do have followings in terms of
being responsible
I think there is no power without
responsibility and I think all artists
ultimately you could choose to be the
Entertainer but at one point our artist
of the conscience of society always and
therefore part of their body rebellious
that's part of their job to be the
conscience and conscience always
rebellious against structure and all
artists we need to carry that
responsibility of being the functions of
society and carried responsibly
and mr. Rushdie is saying that the
banning of the film is like cultural
terrorism it's a cultural emergency that
we are not able to see the film in India
right now and there's a two-week ban or
however long they have what's your take
on that I think Salman is completely
right I think he said the right thing I
think that what happens is fringe moves
come in and take over and the fear of
violence by these fringe groups often
will stop any kind of cultural identity
or film or cultural growth and I think
it's the state's responsibility not
responsibility to ban the films but to
ensure that there's no violence I mean
that's why we like to have an elected
government so I think that's really is
cultural terrorism is caused by the
inability of the state to stop violence
provoked by French
thank you so much
I'm sure this is a very emotional time
where are you finding your strength much
brain yes the audience yes
okay and you know we've seen responsible
tweets on Twitter what do you feel is
the responsibility for you for the
people of India to tell them and to help
them I have honed all the time and now
what I have to say is that you have
trusted me all along I've been fair I
love people I have no religion but have
people who love of any religion I
respect them as places allow I get and I
respect the love I give wonderful good
luck for tonight